hello everyone I'm Ben Platte I'm here
at BuzzFeed and I'm gonna tell you about
my first times first memory from working
on dear Evan Hanson the first memory I
have is going in for the first ever
reading of it
like the first time we ever sat down
just to hear it out loud well they were
very much still developing it really
early on before there was any
productions or anything I wasn't allowed
to know anything about it going in
because they wanted to see what the cold
read would look like like would it be
like if I just sat down and opened it up
and read and see what the connection to
the character would be like without any
preconceived preparation and I just
remember walking and being deeply
terrified that I was about to play like
who know it's like a drug addict or like
you have to have an accent that I didn't
know how'd it like I truly had no idea
what I was getting into and I opened it
up in his first big speech where he's
like going on and on and on about how
nervous he is and anxious he is about
going to school I was like oh I I got
this I'm already anxious now and then it
worked out pretty well after that first
time you were truly starstruck mm-hmm I
went to see Thoroughly Modern Millie
that was my first Broadway show when I
was I think nine or ten and with my mom
we went backstage and Gavin cRIO took us
around and gave us a tour and kind of
showed us around and I was a starstruck
by him because he's beautiful and so
talented and I was basically copied the
way he's saying and that's how I learned
how to say and be because I was like I
have to be in this world I got to be in
the theater he's the coolest he knows
all these backstage secrets and I was
like my life is kind of set and I kind
of stuck
so first memory from pitch perfect of
course my reefa pitch perfect is that I
came late to the shoot because they had
our they had all been there rehearsing
for a few weeks down in Baton Rouge
where we shot the movie but I was only
in that last number that the treble like
finale number so I missed the first
couple weeks so I remember coming in and
being terrified and then I got there and
I saw that Skylar Astin was playing my
best friend and I didn't know who had
been cast as the lead guy as my roommate
until I got there and saw his head shot
up on the production office wall and
there was just like such a beautiful
sigh of relief because I knew him from
the theater world and we've done a
workshop together and I wanted so badly
to get closer with him and be his buddy
so I was like oh now this experience is
gonna be about that I get to be buddies
with Skylar and now he's gonna dear
friends of mine for many years left him
a lot hi Scott first inside joke he made
with beanie
Oh Nene first inside joke I made a
beanie we had this sandwich this this
man who made sandwiches
in our school cafeteria who really loved
me and beanie and he would love to chat
like to the point where he took way too
long making the sandwiches and our
period for lunch was pretty short and
beanie kept tell him to focus focus
focus and so he calls beanie focus and
he kept saying okay focus okay focus and
that became her name so sometimes call
her okay focus
or the time that she came out of class
just to see that I got my braces off
with my new teeth and pretended she was
going bathroom that's what I do remember
my best friend's first reaction you had
to your Tonio nomination I was in my
apartment with my mom and beanie and a
couple of our other dear friends
watching the nominations and I think the
first reaction was just kind of relief
because I think at that point there was
sober so much pressure put on there's
always so much pressure putting on those
awards and so I just was happy that it
turned out the way we'd hoped and then
immediately was eclipsed by how excited
I was that Mike Fleiss got a nomination
because that was sort of out of left
field and I think Mike was so amazing
the show in such a spectacular actor so
I just remember jumping up and down on
the couch being like it's my first song
you wrote off your new album sing to me
instead the first song that I wrote for
the album was the song called runaway
which is the last song on the record and
I wrote it's one of the two on the
record that I wrote on my own I was
lucky to co-write all the other ones
with really fantastic writers and
Runaways very much a tribute to my
parents it was kind of the first thing I
knew for sure I wanted to write about
was sort of the way that they've sort of
set a beautiful example for me with
their relationship and their sort of
steadfastness and so I knew that it was
kind of gonna be a lovely kind of
epilogue and button to the album and
it's sort of a lullaby and I think it's
a beautiful energy to kind of go out
home so but I highly recommend listening
and order and having that beer your
Alaska first AI M screen name B Diddy
151st song you wrote as a kid I think
the first song that I participated in
writing was sort of a rewriting of the
song my family whenever we have a Bar
Mitzvah or Bat Mitzvah we take a musical
theater song we rewrite it and the
lyrics to be about whoever's apartment
it's of our about Mitzvah it is and so
when I was old enough to participate was
lying sister Hannah's my Mitzvah and we
did this song called a book report on
Peter Rabbit from Charlie Brown musical
we wrote it as a life report on an
aberrant and aberrant my sister and so I
got to contribute a little bit I mean my
dad was the main writer but I made some
rice so look where I am now yeah first
time you've got major stage fright I've
never gotten major stage fright first
time realizing you were famous well I
don't know about that the first time
that I realized that I couldn't
walk out of the house without at least
being a little bit conscious of
something like that was probably after
the Evan Hanson first preview there was
like just a see I mean during the pitch
perfect of it all it was a lot more sort
of sporadic and then then it was a
lovely surprise when someone wouldn't
remember like you're that weird magician
kid but Evan Anson kind of took it to
that next level they were I just
remember looking out the window after
the preview in seeing just like a sea of
blue hats and then walking the stage
door and hearing like shrieking people
and just thinking like this is gonna be
a different level of thing but it comes
with the territory and it's beautiful to
have support but also let's talk instead
of take a selfie if I do ever into you
first time you met your BFF beanie
Feldstein I really love that beanies
appearing in these questions now the
first time I met beanie Feldstein it's a
great story we were out of bat mitzva
about Mitsouko every appears in thus
answers to we ratify Mitzvah and it was
our mutual friend and we met during like
the cocktail hour outside the proper
venue and our friend was like you should
meet each other you both left theater we
were like okay so we sat down started
talking about theater time kind of sped
up and we stayed at that same cocktail
like area table just talking and talking
about theater we missed the entire
moment so we never went inside and just
spent the whole time talking about our
mutual friend is still upset to this day
that we missed the bottom it slow
because we don't know him so well but
then there were no cell phones so we
weren't at the same school so we were
just like bye see ya this was a great
first date and then we never saw each
other it's like two years and then I
finally came back to the same school
that she was at already in ninth grade
on the first day we were like I remember
you every day since we first role you
really wanted that you didn't get my
musical theater school growing up I tend
to get the lead most of the time I mean
I kind of earned it with my seniority
but I really did work for it each time
when we didn't fit on the roof audition
for Tevye because that was the lead and
I as a naive young kid didn't really
look at the quality of the roller just
like this is the biggest role I want the
biggest role didn't get it my best
friend Yael gotta go I basically forced
to do theater with me just hang out with
me
really upset I was like I was cast as
model to Taylor just a smaller role it's
like why am i model but then over time I
learned the role was more correct for me
and it fit my me her personality better
and it was a good lesson in casting and
Yael even amazing performances Tevye
which I have on tank the Emmy the first
thing you did after winning a Tony Award
after when a Tony Award I did karaoke
with a bunch of my best friends
room in Koreatown and screamed and
shredded my voice pretty much
purposefully because I had been so
careful over the last like four years
before that and then got really drunk
and then woke up the next morning and
ordered Panda Express and Pizza enemy
player first time you heard yourself on
the radio first I myself on the radio I
think it's on my social media somewhere
I was in an uber and the the ad for Ivan
Hanson played it was way in the
beginning during previews and it was
Otway me singing waving through a window
and it was just this guy in the zubur
and he was like bopping along and really
liked it and I'd like to hold him and I
was like do you know that's actually me
and he was like no it's not it was like
no it's fully me he's like oh it's not
me didn't believe me but it was sir okay
last one first kiss Wow
interestingly my first kiss was with a
girl named Tori Leibovich who will
probably be watching this and we were in
fifth grade and we read Danny meer her
Rooney's birthday party
hope you're watching the enemy harmony
and we were boyfriend and girlfriend as
much as you can be in fifth and sixth
grade and they were like you guys should
go behind that bookcase in case each
other you're like no we're not gonna do
that
everyone's like go behind the bookcase
we went behind the bookcase and had
simply the shortest whisper of a peck
you could imagine and that was my first
kiss that's all I got you guys should go
and listen to my album sing to me
instead it's out now I think you really
liked it it's been a pleasure thank you
BuzzFeed see you later
[Music]